We discuss all parties
Know who to vote for in this election.
which is taking place today confederation
The confederation is definitely
a party focused on its message
Liberal economic views
You know,
lower taxes.
in this economic sphere the confederation
is definitely strong
trying to win his electorate here and that is the thing
on which it focuses
When it comes to worldview issues,
they
if the confederation play rather 2nd violin is hidden
are behind but definitely
if we look at their members and look at this
What they say themselves
The Confederation is a conservative party.
very conservative
With no such nationalistic overtones
No is no coincidence
that the national movement is one of the parts of the confederation
because the confederation consists of a national movement
with new hope
or once yy Corvinists
and from the crown yy Gregor Braun
As we said
The party is focused on its message.
liberal economy and here we have a lot of things
that they promise about in their program
we have a voluntary zus for entrepreneurs
which in this campaign is even picked up by yy
Other parties too
We want to remove 15 taxes by 1 law
Although yy remember
We are talking about the lower taxes.
Rather like a sugar tax
emission fees and so on
We're talking about these taxes.
Because of these high taxes
the confederation relay appears in them
but it also often rains
that no removal will be possible only too much
very long if the confederation had long ruled
going further
we have demonapolization of health care
Introduction of a Health Bonus
so it's a nod to
at least part of the healthcare system
We have a postulate to end the distribution
what exactly does it mean
You know,
in a sense.
no end of giveaways Just
and tax simplification
which is the general yetium of Polish politics
I mean,
every OD party always promises that.
but no one saw
But this is a message
which they focus on from an economic perspective
Now on to the social perspective
which in the confederacy is less accentuated
Probably because of this
That her voters are statistically,
uh, more liberal.
worldview than such acts in the confederation
The Confederation as a Party
but from social things certainly a loud thing
They actually talk a lot about
This is an anti-immigration policy.
this is the thing
which confederation now takes to the banners
Especially in the face of the last things
What is happening in Poland
It is a Eurosceptic party and it is quite strong.
on many levels
but in his program he officially says
Mainly about Politicians
on ecology in the context of the European Union
There is not much in the program
but it's a lot
such
attacking the European Union is more
Use of betting
more and things like that so yy in the program are soft
softer than what is often
hear from their mouths and activists written
have rationalized access to weapons yy
have an educational voucher
a nod to education
some home alternative education
what goes with this general vib of privatization
Public services
But generally in the social sphere
The Confederation is a Conservative Party
definitely with quite strong
Catholic Influence
what we would call it
here I don't know
Let this be an example
that bosak Ali is doing it
The Confederacy was the only party.
In which all members
who were yy signed the application
to the construction tribunal
who later went to the tribunal and
There were no women's protests.
Abortion these things
I don't know if you remember loud events.
in Poland the federation is definitely a party of young people
I mean,
young people mostly vote for confederation.
So what are these things about strictly young
what the confederation says
have a demand for apartments cheaper by 30%
Which also affects the housing market.
The Needs of Young People
The idea is to do this
that if they limit the necessary permission
Necessary paperwork and in general
is like a lower standard
Overall for this industry
then they come out
If the market is deregulated
These apartments can be up to 30% cheaper.
This is a demand for young people.
Yes, because the apartment
on climate policy
The Confederation is a Party
you know more procharcoal you know
combustion cars and so on
Is it a party very much for deregulation?
As we say with the European Union
disagree on most issues
when it comes to ecology and is generally a party
for which ecology in this sense
you know exactly
different things related to ecology
to be more climate neutral and so on
it's definitely not important
even often takes on the banners in some way
Such arguments
that this ecology is not entirely
We should be interested
it's not the most important thing
We should aim for the precious queen
you know that a single-family house
2 cars children
Labradors and so on
not in the sense that you know the vision
yy American submit
1960s
This is the average climate policy.
and at the end
What are the controversies related to the confederation
What your critics will tell you
After the 1st confederation rubber letter
They are quite loudly commented
often have very peculiar views of reality
So quite unpopular
and not always in accordance with
dominant dys scientific course and
The scientific consensus
it's such a common thing
which in the confederation is drawn out and acts in this way
Some of the ones on the lists are like that.
No names are stronger in this respect.
and further into the list
This is often interesting
After the 2nd Federation
There are much larger social conservatives than this one.
which present at the 1st glance here an example
which we can give is even an interview with a man
In which the man stated
to the question
What is more important to him,
I guess?
no state context
is it yy Jesus or the constitution said
Jesus is the most important thing.
to which I refer
What is you know
Well,
from the perspective of throwing a country quite strong
They think no and show what we are talking about.
But this is a social thing.
They focus more on the economy.
and here comes thing number 3 critics of confederation
Accused of confederation
He doesn t really know the economy.
only offers a very simple solution
to pretty hidden problems and really you know
use this image of experts
even though he doesn't deserve it
so now you have a summarized square
stick to see the summary of other games
See you at the election Hello